[Musica]
come va
bene Parliamo di complessità del fa
ridere quanto è difficile far ridere
ad esempio dopo la performance che ho
visto io potrei farvi una spaccata e so
che ci riuscirei perfettamente
cosa ridete
Allora c'è una teoria abbastanza diffusa
sulla infelicità del comico proviamo a
parlarne un po' no perché la maggior
parte dei comici sembra di capire che
debba essere per forza triste infelice
problematica no Un comico serio che
sembra quasi no come amico serio una
cosa che non funziona un comico serio
devi avere per forza avuto una vita
travagliata o comunque molto breve muore
giovane e male
Per questo io mi tengo sempre al di
sotto della media
l'unico che è riuscito finora a salvarsi
è Woody Allen Woody Allen da poco
compiuto 86 anni sembra in forma
nonostante abbia avuto una vita che
avrebbe fatto arrossire Charles Manson e
abbia avuto una produzione artistica in
umana Difatti Lui dice che non ha smesso
di lavorare neanche una domenica cioè
lavorato sempre Woody Allen anche per
questo abbiamo un sacco di roba sua Ah
perché è riuscito a sopravvivere Woody
Allen secondo me per due qualità
fondamentali La prima è che un uomo
dotato di una straordinaria arguzia e
quindi non si lascia sedurre da certi
pruriti autolesionisti no che possono
avere le persone insicure come comici
e la seconda qualità Va beh riguarda la
sua etnia lui è ebreo e quindi per DNA
deve per forza sopravvivere a qualsiasi
cosa
ora ultimamente
Woody Allen ha pubblicato la sua
autobiografia che si chiama A proposito
di niente un librone Come immaginerete
no Visto appunto ne ha di cose da
raccontare avrebbe voluto pubblicarla
anche negli Stati Uniti Ma negli Stati
Uniti nonostante immaginate che
operazione commerciale potesse essere no
pubblicare l'autobiografia di Woody
Allen cioè no ce n'è di roba da dire
nessuno ha voluto pubblicarla
Ma la cosa ancora più bizzarra è che la
biografia l'autobiografia di Woody Allen
è stata pubblicata in Italia
Cioè non siamo così come
è stata voi Leggetela perché intanto è
una vita che vale la pena di no di
essere letta e di essere raccontata
perché Guardate ci sono tante
autobiografie che non dovrebbero non è
obbligatorio scrivere libri e
soprattutto che parlano non è che sembra
a volte no invece quella DVD Allen vale
la pena ehm
a pagina 65
Woody Allen parla proprio del dibattito
secolare sull'eventuale grande tristezza
del comico e contraddice anche questa
tesi lui a pagina 65 se Comprate la mia
stessa versione dice ehm ho avuto
un'infanzia felice Non sarei dovuto
diventare ciò che sono diventato adesso
e questo contraddice no tutti coloro che
hanno sempre detto che la ricetta del
comico perfetto È un'infanzia non dico
Insomma stuprata ma comunque molto
vicina alla violenza o comunque una
storia travagliata in ambito familiare
affinché una persona abbia senso vie
humor
Guardate che non tutti sono dotati di
sensore Questa è una scoperta assurda
curiosa che ha fatto Freud
io non lo amo ma lui tra una riga di
coca e l'altra ha tirato fuori questa
questa cosa curiosa apparentemente cioè
che non tutti siamo dotati di senso
dell'umorismo che magari Insomma
consollerà tante persone che dicono vedi
perché allora quello non è uno stronzo
semplicemente manca il microchip Ok
allora finché una persona sia non
soltanto dotata di senso dell'umorismo
ma riesca anche a farne un mestiere Beh
sembra scientificamente provato che
questa persona che chiameremo comico
deve essere prima trapassata dalla
tragedia
e deve essere sopravvissuto a quella
tragedia e nella maggior parte dei casi
sopravvissuta quella tragedia Grazie
all'ironia
il più grande studioso di umorismo fa
ridere che che esista Ma insomma È
esistito è un biologo che si chiama
Gregory bateson è un biologo ma è anche
il più grande esperto che abbiamo avuto
di processi schizofrenici
Ecco forse perché ha studiato i comici
Comunque è da vedere behson tra le sue
gigantesche teorie molto interessanti ne
ho detta una apparentemente molto banale
cioè che la risata è uno dei soli tre
comportamenti che sono biologicamente
associati a delle convulsioni che non
siamo in grado di controllare
gli altri due comportamenti oltre alla
risata
sono il dolore profondo e l'orgasmo per
chi l'ha provato ovviamente dunque
Questo forse potrebbe spiegare no la
teoria per cui la maggior parte dei
comici appunto porta con sé un dolore
profondo e l'altra maggior parte è
Depravata no se leggete appunto un po'
di biografie
Se incontrate Un comico che le entrambe
avete davanti un genio inchinatevi per
terra Ecco
risata
amplesso e dolore profondo una piccola
digressione sull'amplesso visto che si
parla di complessità amplesso e
complesso hanno la stessa etimologia
Forse perché
è la cosa più difficile da ottenere
Comunque basta con queste battute di
poco di poco conto Allora torniamo a
bomba ok risata dolore profondo Quindi
pianto Quello coi singhiozzi la risata
con le convulsioni e il complesso il
vostro non lo voglio sapere Sono tutti e
tre collegati da questa capacità
dell'organismo di liberarsi dal
sopralluogo della mente
cioè quando noi
effettuiamo questi queste tre
consuetudini che per fortuna ancora
abbiamo è come se dessimo una specie di
pasolare al nostro corpo Avete presente
quello che danno a Ibiza questo passo
dove poi free drink stessa cosa un passo
là che abbiamo al nostro corpo in cui
gli diciamo Vai liberati tira fuori
tutto quello che devi tirare fuori
scopri delle cose di te stesso che
pensavi di non sapere proprio attraverso
questo meccanismo che non riesce a
controllare
chi sta telefonando
vi faccio più ridere Ecco mi avete fatto
perdere il seno
Ma per fortuna il vicino
Oh allora
[Musica]
Eccoci qua
quando proviamo un orgasmo quando
abbiamo un grande dolore e una grande
risata diamo questo passo l'aria al
nostro corpo e gli diciamo Vai lo puoi
fare
è gratis non c'è da vergognarsi non è
pericoloso Era da tanto che avresti
voluto farlo Non è vero
non sono frasi rassicuranti da dire al
vostro corpo io le trovo delle frasi
molto rassicuranti e sapete qual è
l'obiettivo primario dell'umorismo della
nascita dell'umorismo
è proprio la rassicurazione
e questo accordo che si stipula tra chi
fa ridere e chi ride persone che non si
conoscono che all'interno del momento in
cui si fa una battuta e si riceve la
battuta crea questo incantesimo un
incantesimo che appunto avviene tra
persone che non si conoscono è una cosa
meravigliosa ma cosa serve se no
l'umorismo
ad Attenuare il loro orvaku della nostra
esistenza tutti l'abbiamo questo terrore
della vita
e questo terrore della vita
probabilmente Dio a un certo punto si è
reso conto che comunque era abbastanza
pesante da affrontare e ha detto creiamo
l'ironia che sia in grado di abbassare
la temperatura di abbassare il volume
di questo horror qui
l'ironia 15 permette di sostenere il
mondo prima ancora di viverlo ci
permette di avere
un ingrediente fondamentale a ciò che la
nostra esistenza cioè la leggerezza di
più bassa o questa leggerezza perché
adesso si parla solo di leggerezza di
resilienza
questa parola che ormai veramente mi
provoca immediatamente la dissenteria Ma
per fortuna manca poco sì la leggerezza
io la intendo Non appunto come
resilienza perché difficilmente usciremo
Vivi da questa vita
e adesso poi la resilienza però ecco la
leggerezza intesa come la capacità di
diminuire il peso specifico delle cose
degli eventi e delle persone
per questo Noi diciamo prendiamoci poco
sul serio è esattamente così
l'ironia la risata è un farmaco
omeopatico che ci dà questa possibilità
da utilizzare Dobbiamo però esserne
provvisti a 800.000 milioni di proprietà
benefiche però il tempo sta scadendo
Quindi ve le andrete a vedere su uno dei
testi di Gregory batson tipo l'umorismo
nella comunicazione umana è molto
divertente Io vi dico la mia proprietà
preferita in assoluto dell'umorismo che
forse è il motivo per cui ho scelto
questo mestiere quella capacità di farci
digerire delle cose che non saremmo in
grado di digerire delle verità terribili
che non vorremmo sentire ma che sappiamo
dentro di noi Ecco l'umorismo arriva
aggiungendo appunto ehm la risata come
ingrediente e ci permette di deglutire
queste verità terribili e quando si
compie questo incantesimo vero e proprio
lì c'è la satira
Che bella
ma si sta estinguendo
Qual è il nemico numero uno della satira
perché sta andando via ormai da questa
epoca
perché abbiamo paura di offenderci
in questo preciso momento nel mondo
è pronta una minoranza a offendersi ne
crescono così dappertutto
Fateci caso non si può più fare una
battuta sul covid sulla nato sul
femminismo sulla comunità lgbt si
possono fare battute si possono fare
battute sugli ebrei No solo su Woody
Allen si possono fare battute sugli
Italiani sì perché insomma siamo eh
D'altronde barzellette ai Carabinieri
italiani
ma il comico o Chi decide di
intraprendere questa professione
riceve un manualone grosso così con la
regolamentazione della battuta
che è proprio il segreto per svilirla
per non farla neanche nascere una
battuta che scientificamente provato
avrebbe potuto guarire qualcuno
lenire il dolore a qualcuno
o avrebbe potuto
far uscire
una verità che tanti attendono
ora non devo dirvi io il mio pensiero
anche se lo immaginerete su quanto una
battuta vada calmierata su quanto la
satira vada contenuta su quanto
l'umorismo va da reso Borghese ma vi
saluto con un contemporaneo di bateson
che si chiama Yankees un uno psicologo
roba da niente
1952 questo signore quindi parecchi anni
fa ma sempre attuale si alzò durante un
congresso in cui c'era anche bateson e
disse lo scimpanzé è il secondo animale
che quando vede un altro animale o un
uomo ridere di lui si offende
non rallentiamo l'evoluzione più di
quanto sia già stato fatto questa è la
sfida più complessa In bocca al lupo